Brandis in Jacksonville Florida hi
brandy how are you hi babes I'm great
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up so currently my husband and I we have
separate accounts and we really handle
our finances completely separate these
went the rent and utilities everything
else is on our own I brought sixty
thousand dollars of debt into the
marriage not including my student loans
and I'm once as far the debt snowball
method to pay it off slowly I'm also
starting grad school next week and we're
expecting our second child you're
starting what next week
graduate school graduate school and you
have a baby on the way and you're in
debt and you make 60,000 what are you
going to study in graduate school next
partitioner me as far as budgeting but
I'm having difficulties even though
we're in a paycheck-to-paycheck
situation you know he'll tell me he's
been a budget better but then he'll
still eat out or spend unnecessary money
and I'm not comfortable getting a joint
account with him and we're on the same
page budget wise okay all right let me
tell you this is not going to good
places I've been doing this for 30 years
and what you're telling me is not good
it's a lot worse than you think it is
the two of you immediately need to
address this in your relationship you're
you're acting like your roommates for
God's sake do you split who buys the
mustard I mean it's unbelievable
it's ridiculous you and you got married
the preacher said and now you are one he
did not pronounce you a joint-venture
and you need to combine your incomes
combined your debts for better for worse
in sickness and in health for richer for
poorer together we're doing this he's
not your roommate you're not his
roommate and this is a you know we took
this on we're doing this so you guys
need to sit down together you need one
checking account one budget one income
and one set of debts that we're paying
off and
of goals that were both trying to
achieve together and that can be babies
in graduate school and it can be getting
out of debt it can be building wealth it
can be travel I don't care what your
goals are but you need to combine your
goals and you need to combine the
process to get there which is the budget
and combine your incomes to get to those
goals this is this is the precursor for
divorce couples who operate this way
don't stay married now today today you
don't believe that but I'm telling you
I've been in this for 30 years
sometime in the next five to seven years
this is this this split that you all
have done inside the house is going to
get formalized you're gonna have a
problem because you're both trying to
live separate lives instead of being
married it's relationally a disaster
you're pulling at each other like a
roommates and you know he's not it's not
it's not your bed it's our day you got
married it's not his debt it's our debt
you got married it's not his income it's
our income my wife Sharon hasn't had a
personal income in 32 years but we have
an income we have an income she has as
much right legally morally spiritually
relationally to the income as I do and
you don't think she does try getting a
divorce
they have this thing called alimony you
don't think she's got rights to that
income she's got all kinds of rights to
that income even though she didn't
personally go create it in any state so
you know that you really really really
really really and if he won't sit down
the to you can't work through that then
you need to sit down with your pastor
you need to sit down with a good
marriage counselor and work this through
please get on one page not only is it
tactically and practically much easier
to operate your household when you're on
one page and then one checking account
but it forces the two of you to combine
your goals your fears your dreams if
forces you to talk about the future it
even forces you to talk about the past
it forces you to deal with these things
and as you do that then you're gonna see
an increase in communication you're
gonna see an increase in everything in
your marriage the quality of your
marriage you're going
see every bit of a change please please
please come by or combine everything
thanks for calling